[Music]
there is Levine picked up by Tucker on a
switch fires up three
Zach Levine with 20 in the first meeting
he had all the nicknames for the dunks
shot the Thunder sticking him under here
yeah he's flirting with what would be a
71st career triple-double
oh give me the hot sauce at Levine
okay
Levine with a three yeah see I like that
exact location
it's hard to remember Harris in
Milwaukee that feels like so long ago
fading running jumper no buchevich
another board 16 now
Levine pops a three and hits oh give me
the hot sauce Zach Lavine
just much of it trying to match up with
Harold Levine a deep three soldiers of
six I told you catch and shoot he's
right up there with Klay Thompson
feeling it
step back three oh let me step back and
kiss myself
here is Maxie a tough shot with dosumu
defending
our numbers yep Levine again is he
feeling it you bow give me the hot sauce
11-0 run watch this right here good find
by Kobe he said hey take that with you
prank prank prank
Sriracha but Colby white is out there
with the four starters because he could
spread the Florida's playing D Zach okay
bang bang bang okay this is what I said
about Zach LaVine two minutes to play
[Applause]
baby
[Applause]
the three-point line oh my goodness
eleven threes the second most shooting
night
he goes right to the point boom see this
isn't like Klay Thompson type shooting
Klay Thompson remember the night
remember he had what was it 60 in a game
14 and 19. 11 for 13. he had 19 points
alone in that third quarter